more women have been inspired to run for
office this year according to Rutgers
University 468 women filed to run for
seats in the House of Representatives
118 of them are Republicans finding more
diverse candidates is a passion project
for Republican congresswoman Elise
Stefanik of New York the youngest woman
ever elected to Congress so phonic says
they've tripled the number of GOP women
running for the House since last cycle
she volunteered to lead recruitment
efforts for the National Republican
Republican Congressional Committee
congresswoman Stefanik is here with us
at the table good morning great to have
morning very you are definitely on this
mission and when I heard you were coming
on I recall Gail's interview with
speaker Ryan and she showed him a
picture of House leadership and they
were all white men Gail said she felt
excluded he said he's working to change
that what are you doing to work to
change that image and perception as well
so this job as chair of recruitment I'm
the first woman to hold this position
and it was a job that I sought out I
think we need to encourage
non-traditional candidates to run for
office which is why I focused
specifically on recruiting women on
recruiting Hispanic candidates on
recruiting african-americans in in my
experience I was not recruited to run
for Congress so I understand that we
needed to think more broadly and I often
thinks non-traditional candidates in
this political climate are the most
effective members of Congress and the
most effective candidates particularly
in swing districts so this is a positive
news story it's great to see women
running on both sides of the aisle were
more bipartisan and we need to increase
our numbers in Congress to be more
reflective of the population at large
you are women are more bipartisan you
say absolutely so I'm in the top 10% of
the most bipartisan members of Congress
that's something I'm proud of that's
something that I ran on and if you look
at our voting records and the bills that
we introduced women tend to be more
bipartisan than our male colleagues
it seems so at least in Congress right
now everything is so tip for tat it's us
against them there doesn't seem that
bipartisan word doesn't seem to work
very well right now in fact you've
disagreed with President Trump and I'm
wondering how you navigate those waters
so I represent the North Country I
represent a district in upstate New York
and I have to appeal to swing voters and
I
it's very reflective of my political
philosophy I think younger people tend
to want to reach across the political
divide my district voted for President
Obama twice and President Trump so you
know I focused my campaigns on not just
reaching out to Republicans but
Democrats and independents and I try to
put forth common-sense policies that
appeal to both parties you've disagreed
with him about tariffs you you also
don't think Scott Pruett should have the
job he's done you've also spoken out
about how he's held that it's being
handled with the immigrant families have
you heard from him when you disagree you
know I haven't heard directly from the
president I work with this
administration on issues where I agree
but when I disagree I will say so loudly
and clearly and what I think is again if
you look at these swing districts across
the country we need to appeal beyond
party lines and I think that makes
Congress function more effectively as an
institution which is why recruiting
these non-traditional candidates is so
important for the future of Congress one
of the challenges for recruiting women
is appears today in the New York Times
Susan Bevin and Susan Coleman who
describe themselves as pro-choice
Republicans say they're leaving the the
pieces titled why we are leaving the GOP
and a sentence from it says as
pro-choice Republicans we refuse to
support a party that has rightly earned
the labels anti woman and anti common
sense what's your response to that so my
response to that is I think that all
issues are women's issues and I've tried
to urge our urged congressional
leadership on both sides of the aisle to
focus on how all policies specifically
impact women I think we are moving
beyond this siloing of women's issues
tax policy impacts women economic
confidence manufacturing agriculture
policy veterans care so I you know I
disagree with that assessment they
obviously have the right to take that
position but I think my leadership shows
that women care about all sorts of
issues in the district that I represent
Democrats are accused often by
conservatives of being a party in which
you can no longer be against abortion
rights do you think that's the case and
is that as somehow an opportunity for
Republicans so I think we're seeing a
Democratic Party shift further and
further to the left not just on that
issue by a number of issues we're seeing
this play out actually in the Democratic
primary process in my district I'm
facing a very crowded field
Democrats and I think when you look at
again swing districts in the country
where you need to appeal to independent
voters that's gonna be a challenge for
the Democratic Party in those swing
districts women voters are very
important they are having as Republicans
tell me trouble with this president Mitt
Romney wrote a piece about how he
balances supporting the party and
presidents he said I will I have and
will continue to speak out when the
president says or does something which
is divisive racist sexist anti-immigrant
dishonest or destructive to democratic
institutions how can Mitt Romney used
those words to describe the president's
actions how does that square with the
fact that you're trying to get women to
vote and participate who have trouble
with those very same words Mitt Romney
used so I think women in my district
voted for President Trump and there are
many congressional districts where
that's the case across the country I do
agree with Mitt that he is running to
represent the people of Utah just like I
am running to represent 700,000
constituents in my district that's who I
work for that's who I need to make sure
that I advocate on their behalf so I
have a very similar position in that I
work with this administration on a
number of issues where I agree but where
I disagree especially sometimes with the
tweets and the rhetoric I will say so
and I think we need those types of role
models in Congress well tomorrow's a
Democratic primary going up against you
who are you pulling for you know what I
it's great it's great to see women
raising their hand and running for
office
I mean facing a woman in it and this is
a tough political climate I experienced
that I think all elected officials
experienced that and I give anybody
credit who is willing to step into the
arena we need more young voices and we
need more women's voices all right it's
nice to see you in person after nor did
the story on you I know she's sorry she
wasn't here at the table to see you
herself well it's an honor to be here
good to have you here today
congresswoman Stefanik we thank you
again